of calling parents racist liberal
comedian bill maher calling out the left
smear campaign against moms and dads who
turned out big for glenn younkin the
lefty hosts schooling guest michael eric
dyson over critical race theory
they're not objecting to black history
being taught there are other things
going on in the schools can we just
like separating children by race
and and describing them as either
oppressed or oppressor i mean there are
children coming home who are feel
traumatized by this
that's what's that's what parents are
objecting to
katie do you think michael eric dyson
really believes that this is all about
whether schools are teaching the history
of slavery do you think he really
believes that
i think that michael eric dyson is a
racist and this week that he he deduced
and
you know degraded winston's years by
calling her a black mouth moving
speaking about white supremacist ideas
so i think that he likes critical race
theory i think he doesn't want real
american history to be taught because it
shows the promise of america and that we
can get over really tough things in this
country and come together despite our
skin color instead he wants to continue
to separate people by race because
that's his ideology and it's not just
now i mean he's had this ideology for
years and years and years and he gets a
pass
as a professor at georgetown i believe
and he continues to spew this kind of
hateful
rhetoric so i do think that he wants
critical race theory taught because it
aligns with his very racist ideology and
his statements when it comes to anybody
who has a differing opinion especially
if you're a black woman in virginia who
gets elected by parents of all different
stripes and backgrounds because you're
concerned not just about critical race
theory but about other
issues of education in the state
glenn younkin famously said he wants
everything about this country's history
taught the the good the bad and the ugly
yeah and so i recommend can i recommend
an article
danny barefoot is his name he did a
focus group of suburban women in
virginia they had voted for ralph
northam
and biden and then flipped to glenn
yunken so i want to say what do they
have to say well it wasn't about
critical race theory for them the
education issues were very broad it
wasn't the fact that
learning loss from covid shutdowns were
really on their minds falling test
scores they're concerned about their
children not being able to compete um
the fact that you have school closures
like that continued a little bit better
now but the whole mass mandate thing
went back and forth also the safety of
students don't forget what happened in
loudoun county that was on local news
all across virginia and
glen younkin had an applause line about
bringing and offering advanced math in
every high school in virginia that was
an applause line so that's not about
critical race theory that's about
parents who want their kids to be able
to come people clapped for math yeah wow
that wouldn't have been it i would have
sat right in my hands right your
thoughts well i mean the funny thing
about that the bill maher thing is
there's a huge blind spot for people
that favor crt
they never they can't show us the good
parts so they go what do you what what's
what do you got wrong with it and so
then bill maher will say this is the
problem
but they don't see that as the problem
they see that as the advantage or the
positive attributes of crt so it's like
when you ask somebody about crt
what they will tell you is exactly what
scares people it's like yeah we're
creating this you know this oppression
politics it's about the oppressor versus
the oppression we're getting kids at a
very young age to accept accept the fact
that this is a racist society and that
your parents are probably racist because
they're in that society but you gotta
always go back to the science no child
is equipped with enough brain matter to
deal with race or gender especially when
you see that the parents the parents
can't even uh address these top address
these topics without beating each other
up
lastly tyson dyson believes that this is
like basically just white parents right
worried about their white kids no it's a
lot of non-whites who realize that
instilling this kind of righteous it's a
righteous victimhood
and
it can quickly turn any promising
overachiever into some petulant failure
because if you become successful through
victimhood then you'll only be
successful through victimhood because
that'll quickly replace the same thing
with any kind of woke ideology it
replaces a deeper thought that you
should be chasing michael eric dyson has
a name similar to yours harold ford jr
would you like to talk about that or the
actual topic that is the strangest
transition that's a segway yes uh the
michael eric dyson i don't think he he's
not a racist i think he should have him
on the show you should have him on your
show i think you'd find him interesting
you guys would have a great debate i
used to debate him on a different
network
think about this and i mean and i think
i think you would probably agree he's a
decent guy think about this i think
brian kilman who we had on the show you
had on the show last week has written a
book about douglas
and lincoln and he's unearthed in some
things we didn't know about that
relationship now that relationship what
he unearthed will probably unsettle some
people on decide that they don't want to
hear that because they think lincoln was
there so they didn't want to hear that
because i think douglas was this but the
fact that he's gone about this heavy
heavy research deep research to uncover
these things i think only makes the
public space better stronger for that
matter the canon better brett bear wrote
a book on grant and he's on earth at
things about him and his family and how
he rose to power that will only help us
understand grant better and might put in
perspective for those who thought grant
was wrong to end reconstruction he put
in perspective brent did why that
happened how he saved the union how we
were able to get the real railroads
across the country because he made that
deal i'm gonna i'm a proud american i'm
proud of everything that's ever happened
here there's some ugly things that have
happened which i'm willing to confront
and i'm not unsettled by and there's
some unbelievably great things a lot
more of that we have to not be afraid of
words we can't be afraid of a few ideas
i don't want kids thinking they're
oppressor or oppressed but i do want
kids to know what happened in 1800s and
the 1900s and one of the reasons why
neighborhoods and cities and communities
look like they do i'm not afraid of this
and i think any good strong uh
red-blooded american who pays his or her
taxes they won't be afraid of it either
if we do it the right way okay so you
you know you defend dyson and i get it
as a person yeah i i use a person but
there is a weird
there's a new segregation going on and
it's it's not just on skull color it's
on thought so it's like when he says
black mouth white words that's not right
i don't defend that because there's like
no that's like that means that there's
no such thing like you can't share
thoughts there's no it won't work it's
like using the wrong
you know plug for a computer you know it
also means you're defined by your skin
color not by your yeah your thoughts
well what it really is we have set
thoughts about what skin color should
say and do tiger woods should not be a
golfer right doug williams should not be
a quarterback that's the kind of those
are the kinds of set thoughts we have
and if that's what michael eric dyson
was doing he's wrong yeah all i'm saying
is let's have the conversation and not
get upset about it and understand that
people are trying to make the country
better in the process and uh how i saved
the world also unearthed some very
powerful look
in his face
his face was like completely like how
dare he not mention my bro
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else